[Music]
jim is in finley ohio hi jim welcome to
the ramsey show
[Music]
hi dave hey what's up
well i have a little conundrum so um
back in november i was laid off from my
uh job of
many years due to covid and i was able
to find another job
um which i started in mid-january and
unfortunately was in
a different state so i i had kids in
high school
i wasn't going to move them during the
school year i moved down
family you're cutting out
all last thing we heard was you moved
down and you're then your phone cut out
try again i'm sorry about that so yeah i
moved down
and the rest of the family was going to
join me uh after the school year started
um soon after uh
that my wife came down we looked for a
house
because we were going to be moving and
we put a contract on the house to be
built
um and put down
60 000 on that and uh we're debt-free
except for our house so
we had some money saved and everything
else so everything was good
um passport a few more months and
the job did not work out uh the uh the
um uh the principal there decided that
we
weren't working well together and so now
i had
uh no job and moved back to ohio
and uh i'm currently stuck with a house
uh that i have a contract for that i
can't get out of
um and we're not selling the house that
we were going to be selling
in order to uh to uh carry this
and we're unsure what to do at this
point
because um standard mortgage
uh providers you know uh are expecting
you to hold on to a house for
over a year um you know they wanted to
be a principal resident the rest of that
all that is no longer that doesn't that
that won't affect anything that's just
that that means you're not going to turn
into a rental is all you promise to be
owned or occupied but you're just going
to sell it
if you have to close it is the contract
not contingent upon financing
uh well the the contract was contingent
upon
uh being able to show that you could get
financing and i did
was able to show that because we were
you know we were making all that
since then my mortgage provider said you
know under these circumstances
we're not uh interested in uh
in financing you so we're gonna have we
have to find a new way of
financing this have you talked to the
builder
yeah we've tried we tried to get them to
take it back they're actually selling
the same house for forty thousand
dollars more than they paid
us on a new one that they're building
now
um well then why wouldn't they want it
to get back why wouldn't they want it
back i don't
i don't know i don't know i've actually
had a lawyer
work with them to try to get them to
fudge and they're just not budging
okay has your attorney analyzed your
contingency that was removed due to you
having financing approved that is now no
longer approved it seems to me that that
should be an out in the contract
that might be i and he has looked at it
and
um you know we basically had that
contingency when we signed the contract
he's unsure if that can pull us out and
the question is do we lose the sixty
thousand
part of it you know the other thing you
can do is this
um when i used to do flips a thousand
years ago
i would often uh sell a house that i had
under contract
before i closed on it and then have a
double closing
that lasted about five minutes so why
don't you get a good realtor and put the
house on the market now
and put it and put it on the market put
it on the market for what you paid for
it
um which is forty thousand dollars
cheaper than the builder so you'll
undercut the builder who wouldn't
it was too stupid to take it back if i'm
the builder i want this house back
i i agree i don't understand that myself
the only problem with that solution
is that technically they still own the
mls
because we're owners in contract we are
not owning oh i don't care you can
create a whole new mls
a real estate agent can list anything
and you they just list it and say hey
this house is up for sale
and it's undercut it's a you know
construction date to be completed x
and uh by the way it's 40 000 cheaper
than the builders selling the exact same
model for
i think you'll get a buyer in this hot
market and get somebody to buy it
and close it uh one and a half seconds
after you do
and that funds it all right
all right so i'll i'll i'll look into an
elp realtor then
in the other state yeah i think that's
what you need to do and your attorney
needs to get his crap together and start
looking at contingency clause too
because i think you're out
but i could be wrong that's smart that's
a good idea yeah but a
flip like that crap put it on ten
thousand more than you paid for it make
a little money for all this trouble
still thirty thousand less than a
builder selling it for yeah and um
you know and and and let them pick out
the final colors and stuff
let them pick it out yeah and they can
they can still customize it at this
stage
well we don't know when it's completed
they didn't have completion date but uh
that and in this hot market you probably
could do that yeah